- Cette première visite d'une
depuis le début de la pandémie
a commencé en écoutant
les discours nationalistes
des politiciens locaux
aux célébrations de la fête
Mais les parlementaires
canadiens demeurent prudents
dans leurs commentaires sur
la menace d'invasion chinois
politique pour le Québec, PCC
- Alors, moi, personnellt,t,t,
t'sais, je n'ai pas senti ça,
là. On ne sent pas ça. C'est
pour ça que j'ai dit tt,t,t,t,t,
ce n'est pas pareil
que tout ce qu'on ndndnd.
(cliquetis d'appareils-photo)
- Les députés ont visité
les institutions démocratiqu
sur les occasions d'affaires.
le Canada veut assurer
ses approvisionnements
en semi-conducteurs. Taïwan
produit 90 % des micropuces
les plus avancées du monde
Au moment où les Étatss,s,s,
l'Europe et la Chine veulent
augmenter leur propre production
de semi-conducteurs,
devenir un fabriquant.
Ce voyage de la délégnnn
canadienne va aider à élaborer
la stratégie canadienne
indo-pacifique quilalalalalalaln
Ce voyage de la délégation
canadienne va aider à élaborer
indo-pacifique qui doit toujours
être publiée d'ici la fin
de l'année. C'est le souhait
exprimé par la ministre
des Affaires étrangère
♪ ♪ ♪ Cette stratégie vise
à diversifier les liens
économiques du Canada dans
la région, mais aussi à contrer
l'influence de la Chine. Avec
que devrait obtenir le président
Xi Jinping en fin de semaine,
la Chine entend poursuivre
et même accélérer sa montée
en puissance et en influen Ici ,
Radio-Canada, Taïpe